we've come to turkey
to give our relationship a new momentum
and in this respect
we had an interesting first meeting with
president erdogan
we want to strengthen our economic ties
and we will work to modernize
our customs unions framework the eu
turkey statement of 2016
remains valid and has brought positive
results
therefore we expect turkey
to stand by its commitments and to
deliver on them
on our side we will continue to support
refugees
and host communities i'm very much
committed to ensuring
the continuity of european funding in
this area
and our support is clearly a sign of
europe's solidarity to turkey
and an investment in shared stability
the commission will soon make a proposal
that reflects
these principles last but certainly
not least we're aiming for
an honest partnership and that means
that a partnership between the eu and
turkey enables us to strengthen
what brings us closer but also to be
very frank and to address what divides
us
and today shall michelle and i clearly
underlined
that respect for fundamental rights
and the rule of law are crucial for the
european union
this must be an integral part of our
relationship
turkey must respect international human
rights
rules and standards to which by the way
the country has committed itself
i am deeply worried about the fact that
turkey withdrew from the istanbul
convention
this is about protecting women and
protecting
children against violence in some we
want to move
forward towards much better relations in
future
but we are at the beginning of this road
and the weeks and months ahead will show
how far we can go on this road together
you